yo Matt flavours world here
I'm headed to Buffalo another to New
York City on that to North Bergen New
Jersey and everything is fine and dandy
except one thing I hate leaving and we
miss my wife and stuff but you know I
really miss these little filthy [ __ ]
little animals understand because I love
these guys and toughest thing about
leaving well I'm out of town I'm what
was thinking like there's an earthquake
then all the wall in the daytime so this
is I'm packed up I'm ready to go it's
just look at this then Hollywood Joe you
know how this believe this and they know
I'm leaving that's why I can't take my
suitcase out the later
that's right not much I miss this guy
good luck buddy okay
look at him he's a savage I love these
guys i hain't we that's right it's the
own say I love you
I'm in Buffalo New York [ __ ] getting
my show without you this is what it's
really crackin Buffalo we got it going
on
you have to black like this convention
check it out this is what's really
crack-a-lackin' here excuse me
this is Buffalo [ __ ] get some
wings but check this out this is the
real deal here
black bikers invade Buffalo [ __ ] the
road warrior Mel Gibson you understand
me
live in Buffalo at the let's remember
the Anchor Bar will they invented the
wing I got my man Vinny Pete how you
should feel
the Navy died bad flavor here check this
out look at those wings there look at
that week on rolling I'm a horseradish
you have any idea mental [ __ ] it's
not like come on okay and I bought this
buffalo stay black the home of Rick
James
Buffalo New York
see outside [ __ ] Joey Diaz
Buffalo New York places I'm in Edgewater
New Jersey had a Cuban restaurant
knock his socks off Anthony more thing
that we found this dress was negative
join a Vanna the Hudson you understand
me look what they got first off I open
up a little iron via look at that that's
a real Cuban drink little white rice
little black beans little fried bananas
more I am bid but this dish here this is
Bobby J guys you see that you see that
your easel in the middle you know the
last person who made this was my mother
31 years ago and I haven't had it since
with the chorizo because what's the use
there's some things you just gotta
respect that's real Cuban food you'll
never get that nowhere else Jack stay
black man flavors work what's happening
[ __ ] mad flavors well you guys are
like what the [ __ ] are you Joey you
didn't bring up a tape on Monday I'm
busy with your [ __ ] hard-earned
dollars that you sent me thank you again
to put this together a little
documentary I'm in North Bergen New
Jersey let me show you how close North
Bergen New Jersey is the New York City
BAM right [ __ ] there
we're over the [ __ ] bridge this isn't
even New Jersey this is Hudson County
North Bergen turns into the whole Balkan
this is not even particle Jersey people
even listen to spring see in this part
of New Jersey understand me but the
reason why I'm standing here is yeah we
shouldn't documentary and stuff this is
the spot right here where we all get
confused I was confused for a bunch of
years where the guy beat me up and I'm I
tried to mug him now when I first told
the story I said that the guy might have
been a [ __ ] again I got a song that over
the years I've gone about it
this area here wasn't really those type
of people there's more pedophile from
New York that would come over
where he threw the [ __ ] beat now me
and this is this type of stuff you gonna
see in the documentary so get ready a
strap on your seatbelts in that flavors
world thank you again for watching thank
you for making this dream come true you
guys won't be sorry
stay black [ __ ]
so this [ __ ] seems like my eye of
rose with me